Israel's left-wing moretz party has
launched a campaign drawing attention to
a local ban on women appearing on
billboards is also suing to the city of
Bnei Brak and ultra-orthodox region just
east of Tel Aviv which has been removing
women from advertisements well for
example the leader of another Left Party
to Tzipi Livni shown in yellow here was
raised from mrs. virtus meant leaving
her just her male colleagues Livni
responded with a video of herself in
front of the billboard that's not my
face that they're asking to erase those
are your faces faces of Israeli women
over 50% of the population that's your
voice men and women who want Israel to
be a liberal state join the fight
against this that's it that's how it
should be I think it's it's wrong to
blur the face of a woman can't you
control yourself even a little bit I
mean you can see a woman's face anywhere
without getting aroused what's wrong
with you it's a very primitive this is a
free country and we have asked the city
authorities to comment on this story
it's not just the advertisement so
featuring human women that have been
banned last year an image of smurfette
from the comic strip the Smurfs was
removed from a billboard Penny Brax
Authority said they were concerned that
the cartoon character might incite the
feelings of the city's residents we
spoke with Rena Bartel a former deputy
mayor of the Israeli city of banana and
she told us that Orthodox communities
ignore the law when it comes to
religious rules Network it is an
ultra-orthodox community they feel that
they have the right although it's
illegal to take it down these women they
bought the space for their pictures for
the billboards they paid for the space
like everyone else does
and it was taken down so of course it's
not legal I must explain the situation
however
to the ultra-orthodox community it does
not matter if it's legal or illegal it's
something according to their rules and
regulations which is ultra religious
rules and regulations they'd say that a
face of a woman cannot be seen or shown
in public in public domain
you